what's going on guys this is Rob and you
guys love the last video we did where
Lord Zed became a Power Ranger so we got
to follow this up
man and this is the Prelude to Darkest
Hour what you guys are going to notice
over the course of this story is that
literally all the Power Rangers villains
and so on are all going to be unified
against a singular threat because things
are about to pop off so what ended up
happening here and this is one of the
questions that you all had is that
within the comic the question is asked
how did Lord Zed get a hold of of a
Morpher and he just kind of answers it
he says I had a device planted in Zordon
Command Center months ago to drain
Zordon power and steal it for myself and
that's one of the things that we
explained in the last video he had a
Morpher stationed there all he was doing
was just orchestrating his Escape so he
could go and take it and turn himself
into a Power Ranger now one of the
things that I also want to explain here
because this seemed a little lost to
people to a degree in the last video
that we did the nature of the morphin
grid so the morphin grid is not that
dissimilar from like the speed force in
The Flash comics or something along
those lines an external source of power
that people draw on in order to achieve
a level of power that they wouldn't
normally be able to get on their own
right if Zordon is the door that
basically allows access to the morphan
grid then the Power Rangers morphers are
the keys right they allow them to enter
in draw for the morphing grid and that's
how they get their abilities and so on
and so forth and so what this does is
that with Lord Zed orchestrating his
scheme there is something that I do want
to draw your attention to one of the
things that happens is you get a
conversation between try and Zach now
like we mentioned in the last video
unlike the main Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers TV show this comic really
deviates away from the source material
and we know that because Lord Zed never
became a Power Ranger in the show and it
would have been dope if he had but what
you had what we called the Omega Rangers
so in essence instead of like triny and
Zach just kind of going off into Parts
Unknown right doing whatever it is their
characters did in the aftermath of all
that I'm not 100% certain about it
because let's be honest Mighty morph and
Power Rangers is where the show peaked
that in this comic they went and became
Omega Rangers right they're just kind of
out there doing their thing and the
Power Rangers sometimes assist with them
and sometimes they don't but this is one
of those calamities and one of those
situations where anybody who was a
ranger at this point in time is all
unified against the singular cause of
defeating Rita and that's when Aisha
shows up now again I draw this in
because as most of you know Aisha is the
yellow ranger for the Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers at this point in time and
triny went on to become an Omega Ranger
that's something that's important and I
want you to keep that in the back of
your head because what this does is this
transitions to basically Tommy and Jason
just kind of basically working out you
know fighting each other that kind of
thing which is awesome to see because it
was one of the coolest moments from
Green With Envy when Tommy first showed
up and dominated the entirety of the
Power Rangers because let's be honest
Tommy was at his best when he was a
green r rer stop telling me he's not but
the thing here is that in the last video
that we covered Matt who was the guy
that became the Green Ranger after Tommy
became the White Ranger that he was
taken by Rita and he was basically
corrupted which is powerful the course
right it sucks when you're a green
ranger because when you're the Green
Ranger you get taken and corrupted in
some form or fashion and he ended up
just basically becoming a villain keep
in mind this is really happening because
it's just kind of tying back to the
history of the Green Ranger itself drawn
on some measure of familiarity but there
is a really cool thing that sort of
links all this together because what
ends up happening is jumping back to the
Lord Zed this guy makes his move against
Grace now that's one of the things that
we also talked about is the nature of
Grace is she basically works for the
government and the mighty morph from
Power Rangers work alongside the
government but not really for the
government instead of like being this
sort of enigmatic concept that exists
out there in the world like you what you
were probably familiar with with the
show the government's well aware of them
right and really see the Power Rangers
is more something beneficial as opposed
to something that is that stands in
opposition of the government's goals and
Grace is a liaison between the two but
the other part of this is the Navigator
and the reason for this is because what
we had talked about is that Rita's main
mission is to basically find a way to
bring this kind of ultimate Evil back
into reality and using a navigator is
what would take her to one of the Arches
that would allow her to make that happen
it's literally a compass right so having
this points her to where she needs to go
in order to bring about The Darkest Hour
event now the fight between Matt and
Jason is pretty straightforward in the
sense that Jason can't really become a
Power Ranger at the moment but Tommy
can't so Jason's taken out pretty fast
and then of course Billy shows up as the
Blue Ranger doing what he can where he
can but you end up getting this amazing
fight between the Green Ranger and the
White Ranger and this is a dope conflict
here because this fight between the two
is much much bigger than just like
you're a Power Ranger and you're in my
way and I need to get rid of you because
I'm working on behalf of Rita and my job
is to get the Power Rangers out of
commission no no no no one of the things
to know about the character of Matt and
is what he's always kind of struggled
with he sees himself as a replacement he
sees himself as an unnecessary extra one
because the nature of his green ranger
Powers come from the government and
Grace he didn't get his abilities from
Zordon and the traditional Morphin grit
but the other part of this is Tommy's
the original Green Ranger Tommy became
the Ranger but at the end of the day
he's always kind of seen as like a poor
man's Tommy which is true because he is
so what this does is it transitions of
course back over to Lord Zed and the
issue is that Grace tells him Rita's on
her way here like she's coming here now
Lord Zed doesn't really care because for
him it's really more of just like
getting back at the chick that attacked
him before because that's one of the
things to remember that Rita repulsa and
this person that we only know as vessel
had basically like sucker punched Lord
Zed they just just rolled in to Lord
Zed's base of operations dominated
everybody and then kicked him out like
the the Power Rangers literally had to
teleport in and rescue this guy and then
he told him like you cannot defeat
vessel and Rita repulsa they had to flee
for their lives right like there was no
way for them to get out of that alive so
it was a really really cool moment to
see them just on the verge of dying but
this leads to a fight between vessel and
Lord zet now one of the things that I
want you guys to notice in this fight
between the two it's very very even
right I mean literally it's one of these
things where like they're both equal in
terms of power and what they're capable
of even with vessel not traditionally
being a Power Ranger and Lord Zed having
Power Ranger abilities but in this fight
Zed starts to realize something that
this guy vessel is not just an arbitrary
person who's out there sure he seems to
be mindless and sure he seems to just be
following orders but Zed realizes this
person is someone that he knows when he
looks at him he realizes it's the
physical form of Zordon which is crazy
now here's where things get get even
more nuts right here's where it gets
even more nuts right while all this is
taking place while all of this is
happening unbeknownst to anybody someone
with a tattered cloak is literally
bobbing and weaving and sneaking through
they go to one of these great big huge
Gorge right these containers they
basically end up taking the top off and
they free a Girl by the name of Kaa who
is Ka Kaa was at one point a blue ranger
who ended up basically becoming a
villain and then had her Morpher taken
away or seemingly destroyed by Trini she
was imprisoned following that she did
start off as a good guy the person who
freed her is Lord dracken now here's the
thing man for those of you guys who
don't know who Lord dracken is son son
son when Lord dracken came onto the
scene and the Power Rangers Comics they
were not prepared this was a version of
Tommy from an alternate reality who had
the Green Ranger and the White Ranger
Powers this guy showed up and just
dominated everyone and the funny thing
about this is like Kaa freaks out and
attacks him and you wouldn't think that
would be the case right you would think
that like with him being a villain and
her basically being a villain that they
would like unify under their villain
nature no no no no Lord dren is
everyone's enemy right he's like the bad
guy to everybody and it's not because he
sucks it's because he's dope right he's
just like that amazing but he was that
hardcore he literally like wiped out
seemingly everything and in fact
recreated reality at a point in time it
was nuts man dude he was he was such an
amazing character I love Lord dra I'm so
glad that we covered the videos on his
character but what ends up happening is
that following this right while he goes
off with Kaa and he does his own thing
once Lord Zed is defeated by Zordon
physical form it makes its way into the
Power Rangers headquarters and then of
course basically takes out everybody
else who's there because I mean what are
they going to do right and then of
course it makes contact with Zordon now
unlike what you would expect which is
that it would destroy Zordon that's not
what's happening vessel has been working
for Rita repulsa and I wouldn't go so
far as to say that he's just been biting
his time and waiting for the perfect
chance to strike it's actually been
trying to find Zordon because it has an
almost kind of tug right a pull towards
Zordon and a lot of that's because any
kind of knowledge or ability to function
that vessel has is more due to Rita's
magic than anything else by all
standards of measurement it should just
be like a body that can't go anywhere or
do anything more or less the same thing
as like an empty Iron Man suit right but
meeting with the essence of Zordon what
it does is it says show me who you are
show me what you're about and the
discussion between the two is actually
really fascinating because when it comes
to Zordon one of the big things to to
contend with is that over the course of
the Power Rangers TV shows and the Power
Rangers comics and that terrible Power
Rangers Ivan o movie that what Zordon
routinely does is send the Power Rangers
into Harm's Way one part of it is that
if that's just the nature of the job
right I mean you can just throw down
your Morpher and quit if you want to but
due to their own personal moral
compasses and a sense of Duty and honor
they stay the course not every Power
Ranger makes it right over the eons that
Rangers have existed under Z 's control
many have died and in fact it's one
thing that he contends with on an
emotional level and in fact even vessel
says like look at all these different
Power Rangers that you've sacrificed for
your own ends right like you've done
this to them and the reality here is
that Zordon really sort of reconciles
this by saying they understood the
threat of what was happening here and
they understood that with this role
comes some measure of sacrifice and in
fact even vessel says like you are a
leader
who sacrifices those in his care and the
response to Zordon is that was never my
intention and it wasn't right the role
of Zordon is to be a kind of liaison or
a guy who gathers together these
protectors for the purpose of stemming
off some kind of threat that's out there
but it wasn't one of these things where
he's like yes my minions March March to
your doom it was never anything that
nefarious or that basic right in fact
the idea of Power Rangers dying under
his charge haunts zor on right it's a
thing that he'll just never be able to
come to terms with completely and he'll
never be able to accept all those deaths
are on his conscience and so in response
to this vessel actually offers his own
physical form and says you can take this
body it is strong it is infused with the
power of the morphin grid you can
reclaim it and write all of these wrongs
we can become one again you can use this
power and become Next Level right
potentially even resurrect all these
Rangers that had died because the power
of the morphan grid is seemingly
infinite but the response of Zordon is
as much as I desire to be made Caporal I
can feel mistress vile's magic her
corruption it would consume me I'm
afraid you must choose your own path now
and he walks away now that's one of the
big things here right he has an
opportunity to fix all the wrongs right
to write all the wrongs to ensure that
he could fight alongside the Power
Rangers and all that stuff but Zordon
turns it down and it doesn't come from a
place of like arrogance or huous I think
that's an important distinction here
it's not one of those things where it's
like I mean you know I could fight
alongside the Power Rangers you know and
that would be cool but like why would I
sacrifice my life when I could have them
sacrifice theirs but it's not really
that kind of thing right it's more of
this is the path that I have been set
upon and if I were to emerge with you
yes I would become an instrument for
evil and there would be virtually
nothing that I could do because the
magic or the power of Rita repulsa is
simply just too strong and the response
of vessel is to try to absorb the
essence of Zordon into himself and
simply walk away and ultimately Zordon
overpowers vessel right and says no I
have taken your body and I have made it
mine yes I have lost much I have
sacrifice and I have experienced defeat
there is weakness in me but still I find
my strength in them and I will not
falter I cannot no matter the cost right
for all the evil that consumes us there
is always hope there's always Redemption
there is always good I will choose that
and face the consequences every time and
the result of this is that he
effectively purges the magic of Rita
repulsa directly out of vessel and then
says now it's your duty to go forward
outside of the influence of Rita and
choose your own path decide what kind of
person you're going to become now
switching back over to Lord dracken they
basically end up leaving right they kind
kind of go on their own mission of sorts
but they do cross through the master
Arch after activating it with the other
rangers being there and even Lord dren
turning back into his normal form which
is like one half green ranger one half
white ranger and just looking as dope as
he ever did he literally tells all the
other Power Rangers destroy this Arch
destroy this because if you don't if
Rita gets here and she's able to
activate it there's nothing you're going
to be able to do to defeat her it's one
of the cool things about Lord dracken he
was introduced to us as seemingly a
villain with a singular cause but the
longer he'd been around the comic books
the more we learned he knows a lot like
there's a lot he has going on behind the
scenes or at least a lot that he's aware
of behind the scenes that the Power
Rangers just don't really seem to
understand and so it is a phenomenal
thing because it's just kind of like how
deep does this guy's knowledge go right
now switching back over to Matt himself
again facing off against all the other
rangers the reason why I wanted you to
kind of keep in mind that whole thing
with Aisha is that a fight breaks out
between the two of them and leaving
behind any kind of romantic connection
between these characters they're very
very close and the bond that was formed
between the two of them was very much
rooted in this idea that they're both
secondary Power Rangers Aisha came after
Trini Matt came after Tommy and so
because of these two things he and her
to a degree kind of saw them elves as
outcasts right they kind of saw
themselves as like yes we're Rangers but
we're not one of the original Rangers so
we'll never really be Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers in the traditional sense
and it was a really cool way for the two
of them to kind of find some measure of
Solace but then this becomes a weapon
that can be used by Matt against Aisha
creating a moment of distraction a
moment of Doubt is he telling the truth
this was the kind of manipulation that
Rita used on Matt to turn him into a
character that became corrupted well
you're never really going to be one of
their Power Rangers Matt you replaced
Tommy as the as a green ranger how long
do you think it'll be before they
replace you if you're someone who can
just replace someone then you're someone
who can be replaced right you'll never
really matter to them you'll never
really be relevant to them you'll never
be one of them because you weren't there
when they first became Power Rangers
when they were first brought together
none of that is true of course right
they all love the character of Matt they
all see him as one of them but with this
corruption it's one of these things that
he can't get past and that's what's so
interesting about self-doubt a lack of
self-confidence things like that right
we hate the things in others that we
cannot fix in ourselves and he doesn't
feel like he can fix that it's all a
matter of how he perceives himself but
he's locked in this ideology and so it's
a really really cool way to portray his
character and how easy it is for someone
like him to become corrupted and to
ultimately fall and so what the power
Rangers do is they come up with this
idea on how to basically break the
influence that Rita has over Matt which
is in effect using his Dragon Zord to
create the dragon thunder Zord which as
we all know when we were little kids was
like the greatest thing ever in the
history of mankind and if you were a kid
who owned the dragon thunder Zord back
in the day yeah man like the dragon
Megazord dude you were like you were
like the coolest kid it was like being 5
years old and owning a Power Wheel you
know what I mean like you were the kid
that like all the girls wanted to hang
out with I was not that kid but the
thing about this
is true story man I was not that kid I
wish I was but with vessel basically
regaining himself or at least being able
to choose his own path he jumps in the
fight between Lord Zed and Rita repulsa
again kind of transitioning back to that
and of course Rita kind of gives him an
order and then vessel rejects it right
vessel says no ultimately the Navigator
was handed over to her right just by
virtue of the fact that she had Grace
held hostage and it was like you know if
you release Grace we'll give you the
Navigator and then you know you can just
kind of get out of here not fully
understanding what it was capable of or
at the very least hoping that things
could kind of end at a future point in
time but even with the character of Matt
right kind of jumping back to him even
with his character the complicated
nature of this is that the hold that
Rita has over him comes by way of just
more than just bringing him into some
Dragon Thunders Zord and then destroying
the dragon Zord staff that he had right
his his weapon like there was more to it
than that right it's a psychological
manipulation and so he ultimately just
ends up teleporting away and rejoining
Rita repulsa the issue to this is that
one of the things that Rita had been
doing in her time leading up to this was
building an army right she's been
building an army the entire time using a
huge number of forces across all of
creation and it was a smart move right
given the nature and the power of the
Power Rangers themselves they always
kind of come out on top and so simply
just like showing up on the doorstep of
the Power Rangers with nothing but
herself and vessel and expecting to be
able to take the win especially now that
Lord Zed is a Power Ranger that's a
Fool's errand right it was guaranteed
defeat and so this massive just like
Armada is making its way to earth right
jump over to Trini and Zach right who
are just standing there realizing that
Lord dracken had taken off they were
instructed destroy this thing and the
issue that they have here is but like
dracen was the one who gave us that
order we don't know if destroying this
would would literally seal our own fate
we don't know if destroying this would
actually help us when has Lord dra ever
really done anything that's been for the
benefit of anybody other than himself so
they don't really know exactly what
approach to take but before they can
really even take aide and decide what to
do the massive Armada just comes
crashing down right the death Ranger is
here all these guys are here if you're
not familiar with the death Ranger let
me know we can cover that because we
never covered the death Ranger storyline
but it's one of those things where like
literally all her forces that she's been
putting together over the course of this
time all come to Bear but even with
vessel himself right like basically
Zordon physical form even with him
defying Rita repulsa he's still subdued
because her power is simply just too
great and so in that moment Rita ends up
just kind of teleporting away now that
she has the Navigator she makes her
escape and the rest of the Power Rangers
are kind of left wondering what in the
world it is they're going to do but once
Rita gets to the Bea triangle and she
has Grace in her possession and she gets
to this like Master Arch the whole thing
is kind of locked up it's difficult to
open up you know you have Grace who's
just like it's well fortified and
there's safeguards and all that kind of
stuff rotating access codes Rita's like
I mean that's cool and everything but
like check this out and just like
literally smashes the door open using
her power it's one of those instances
where like Grace underestimates the
nature of the threat that she's facing
off against it's not something that she
can easily overcome but for Rita sure
right that was super easy to take out
but for all the forces of Rita right
jumping back to the Power Ranges
themselves for all the the forces of
Rita repulsa the Power Rangers are
basically useless in the face of these
guys right like literally the death
Rangers like will you truly stand in my
way right are you really going to get in
my way here and it's one of these things
where all these different Power Rangers
forces they're unable to hold their own
against this threat it's just not going
to happen right I mean they're able to
kind of do what they can where they can
but stopping Rita repulsa that's never
going to happen there's no conceivable
way to do it by the time the Core Power
Rangers get to the master Arch where
Rita repulsa is she's already casting
the spell right and ancient evil through
the breach with this Arch and Crystal's
might I cast a perversion of the morphan
light and from this infection I create a
path for you to dominate may all who
fear you be overrun The Darkest Hour has
begun literally this ultimate Evil
finally makes its way into reality and
seemingly from everything that we've
been told leading left to this point man
the end is nigh it's game over
especially once we see the rise of the
zombie Power Rangers that's when
everything goes nuts with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you want to get caught up on
our Power Rangers videos make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later peace